hello everybody and welcome to a
very special mid-week
version video taped god help us version
and
above all webathon version of the reason
roundtable podcast
i am matt welch joined as always by
most always uh by our super friends uh
nick gillespie peter suderman
and catherine mangu ward hello everyone
howdy
hey matt happy wednesday people are
gonna hear this
on thursday peter so already you're
wrong footing everything
um i hope you had a happy wednesday oh
okay you're listening to this
um we are going to basically field your
questions uh hopefully get to most of
them i cannot promise that we will get
to all of them
the sooner we actually start asking them
the sooner we can get there so first
before we start
i just wanted to see whether our editor
uh in
in chiefdress catherine mangy ward has
any
kind of you know objectivist prayer you
want to say at the beginning of our uh
of our webathon session here if you're
going to give me a suffix i prefer
editrix
uh although editor-in-chief will be just
fine um no i just wanted to
kick off our webathon podcast by saying
that this is actually one of my favorite
parts
of the webathon and actually of the year
last year we had
such good questions that i actually had
kind of a moment of like oh my gosh our
readers and listeners and viewers are
really great so i guess i just would
want to start out by saying if you've
already donated thank you very much if
you're
thinking about donating thank you very
much but also
even if you're just listening and
sometimes like bothering someone at
dinner
about something you heard on this
podcast you're doing
what we hope you will do with our
content which is share it around
and spread the ideas that we hash out
here
and care deeply about and so even if you
don't have um
lots of bitcoins to throw our way today
um we still really really appreciate
your support as
listeners but if you do happen to have a
couple skip spare bitcoins maybe
hit us up you just said nice things
about our listeners years raiders
um uh i'm going to counteract that by
reading our first question from scott
ewing i'm sure i'm mispronouncing our
good friend scott's
email but he says i will make my annual
donation if everybody on the podcast
including nick refers to him as dr
gillespie love scott we're reading this
first just so we can all get
our dr gillespie's out of the way and
hold you
to that ten thousand dollar pledge scott
that you were talking about so
uh dr gillespie are you are you happy
that dr uh jill biden is going into the
white house
i am uh looking forward uh matt peter
and catherine to
battling dr jill biden uh for the next
four years
uh like sherlock holmes and professor
moriarty forever tumbling off of
reikenbach falls and
i think that my doctorate uh will
achieve ground impact first so
i'm looking forward to the next uh
several years all right let's get into
our actual questions andrew
ballet and i i i'm sorry not sorry in
advance for
everybody's names who i massacre it's
part of you can't say my name so
don't take it personal andrew asks
catherine as the lady anarchist
wow you gotta why do you gotta gender
her uh what's it like working with these
awful statists
how do you not violate the
non-aggression principle
on their asses every time you see them
some of my best friends are statists
it's fine um dr gillespie and i
have actually hashed this out in the
pages
of reason magazine i think reasonable
libertarians can disagree on whether
anarchism should be your ultimate goal
but that we can certainly agree
on a bunch of incremental steps before
we have to decide
about you know privatizing the roads and
the
you know personal security or whatever
we ultimately come to um i think i think
anarchism
is a way of thinking about
how how the world could work better and
that's how i use it i use it as a way of
thinking about if there was
no state how would people do things um
and that's a question
all libertarians should ask themselves
and anarchists just
answer it more thoroughly and more
annoyingly
uh for sure uh i will let our listeners
decide who
is annoying uh and he didn't say single
out peter for that
weirdly uh what's it like working with
the anarchist how do you reconcile
your differences i'll go first just to
say that i do it by uh
always sending catherine my i voted
sticker right after i vote because
that's really fun but
what's it like working with an anarchist
it's fantastic she's a great boss a
great colleague
a great uh sort of uh creative uh
uh creative inspiration i mean a lot of
what we do is sort of
think about how to uh what articles we
should be running how
those articles should work um you know
how they should be structured
like what this particular sentence in a
particular piece should say
and catherine's always super great um
and i think actually though she's also
like
a thing i will say that maybe uh that if
you haven't worked with her you might
not see because it's not
necessarily visible in the public work
product is as an anarchist
who uses the ideas of anarchy to think
about how we can do things better
she ends up being really really good at
in the micro level of our little
institution being really really good at
helping other people
organize themselves in a private way
to do things better you were supposed to
do smack talk there though
that was nice but you were supposed to
take care of that take it away nick
i you know i don't know i see like a
state so
uh it's hard nick is the leviathan
we are uh uh you know it is true that
the uh kind of the institutional uh
organization
is is very decentralized and dispersed
which i think goes a long way towards
anarchy and i like the way that
catherine devolves uh a lot of decision
making
down almost to the cellular level so
that's really good
guys are the two genders actually crisis
and leviathan
oh that's a very good question but then
but
there are 57 genders genders there are
57
genders um i think one for every basket
dr jordan peterson has us taught us that
it is
only two and they are crisis in
leviathan uh anthony
uh andy hawks we
appreciate the uh the nickname in there
andy anthony uh as a regular listener to
the reason roundtable podcast i can't
help but have noticed
good verb tense there that catherine is
called catherine
matt is called matt nick is called nick
peter is called peter et cetera but
stephanie
is almost always called slayed even to
her face
what's up with that catherine uh that is
slade's
preference that is the name that she
goes by her friends call her
slade and we are friends also let's be
real
it's incredibly cool and if my last name
wasn't mangu ward but was instead
slayed i would go by slade and we called
peter suderman
i do recall michael moynihan used to
occasionally call you uh
mango yeah and i loved that yeah
uh my wife used to call radley balco
radlow
which i still use uh mostly uh behind
these matt
if you were going to take a name after a
70s glam rock band though
would you you know would you go with
slade or would you go with somebody uh
you know i don't know like mata hoople
or something obviously the hoople
yeah just half nelson i would do the uh
the glam rug band whose name i'm
blanking on but it's the best ever it's
a rick springfield's
teenage band in australia which does the
single best version of eleanor rigby
ever done and that includes the beatles
all right let's uh go i should probably
say i go by i go by suderman
in our uh slack channel yes sure uh yeah
we we we call them scooterman
uh quite a bit i in fact i don't on the
round table as much as i
would because my uh muscle memory is to
call him suderman computerman
which is what we used to call him on the
independence and he probably still gets
called on kennedy
uh to this day um paul dobner
ask question kovid has made me lose
faith in humanity
which in turn has made me question if
libertarianism could succeed
my question is is this a valid concern
and how can you argue for libertarianism
during a pandemic
when almost half the population doesn't
even believe
in masks paul i'm so sorry about losing
your faith uh nick do you want to uh
to restore his faith in humanity uh yeah
i mean it's
uh you know viruses i assume predate uh
humanity
i mean we you know we can say they're
socially constructed on some level but
i actually have found the past year to
be a
kind of reinvigoration of a lot of
libertarian beliefs again going to the
decentralization of knowledge and as
well as of power and authority
where we've seen the worst mistakes
being made is at the left
after periods where there is the most
centralization of control
um we saw that with the cdc and the fda
making
grievous mistakes early on and we saw
the response
at you know at the state local and even
federal level was to loosen up a lot of
laws and regulations
that kept medicine from being practiced
from uh bringing in uh
different types of ideas about how to
control and contain and beat
the uh the virus and you know talking
about
masked um you know i think it's worked
out pretty well
it just you know forget about mass
mandates
uh there's a lot of information about
there and most people are wearing masks
because they believe that it you know
they help prevent the spread
of infection um and mass compliance is
good i mean like you know people are
making decisions so i i
understand his uh you know his his um
discord his internal discord but i
actually think you know when you see
uh governments waiving certain types of
drug authorization rules and things like
that and opening up the process
when you see the tsa getting rid of
certain limits on hand
sanitizer and other things you can bring
on uh planes
when you see states getting rid of
medical licensing requirements that are
[ __ ] to begin with
um you know this is a time where we
should be talking about how
dispersing uh knowledge authority and
decision making actually leads to better
results
uh catherine anything to add just to uh
inject faith
in a time of coronavirus yeah i mean i
guess i've always thought that
libertarianism is the right response to
a world where people are kind of crappy
and fallible
um i've always been a little bit
confused actually by
by the critique of libertarianism that
like it presupposes that people are good
or rational or
or something like that um because it
seems like
giving one person or a small group of
people
power over a lot of their fellows puts
an awful lot of faith in the idea that
that person
is good or will or will have good
incentives even
which i don't have so yep people
are not great sometimes yep that has
been true in 2020
um and uh and i think you know you're
right that uh pandemic is a challenge
to where are the limits of government
interference it absolutely is that is
and and the you know question about
vaccination is going to be a further
challenge
but i don't think that people being kind
of
crappy and irresponsible a lot of the
time is
is a new challenge or an insurmountable
one i think you know to just
very briefly uh uh discuss a little bit
more you are seeing people push back
against authority that they see as
illegitimate
or uh you know wrong and or not clear
enough and things like that
and you also see in the whole idea of
the federal government giving
a prize for whoever comes up to with a
vaccine
quickest that's kind of a model for a
libertarian not a
anarchist way of doing government but
where the government sets broad rules
and possibly incentives and then kind of
gets out of the way
we are in a moment where the crackdown
is coming we're literally and
figuratively under lockdown
that's very troubling but it's exactly
looking to the libertarian uh
response i think where you see the best
hope for what what things should look
like
during normal times as well as crisis i
would add that we ran a great piece
about
10 years ago or so maybe less about
how the development
of aids hiv therapies through the fda
was a kind of revolutionary new process
that uh that should be followed in the
future and it's very prescient about uh
how
uh for this pandemic as well this you
know if there's going to be an
opportunity that comes out of all this
hopefully
it has to do with the rapid developments
and and kind of opening up of the
process at the food and drug
administration
and that's the memo i'm going to direct
the next one at peter since
he didn't talk on that one scott murray
says this is a pretty good norms
question peter
is trump's refusal to accept election
results
more threatening than biden's mask
mandates what say you well i think
biden's mask mandates
are gonna end up being pretty toothless
it's not even clear
that he is going to attempt a national
mass mandate he might
attempt something like say requiring
masks on all interstate commerce because
biden alone the president alone is not
going to be able to
implement a mass mandate that has to be
done at the state or the local level
um i think there's just a a real
deep issue that you have to be worried
about when the president refuses to
accept
legitimate election results and instead
clings to
absolutely bonkers completely unfounded
crazy theories
that the election was stolen from him
the
the peaceful and mutually agreed upon
transfer of power is the foundation
for democratic governance you have to
have that
and trump isn't going to end that trump
isn't going to
throw our country into some sort of uh
apocalypse
of democracy where it's just all over
and there's a new civil war
but what he's doing is just chipping
away at the foundations
and he and every single day that he's
out there saying look this election
was stolen it was fake it's illegitimate
he's embarrassing himself but he is also
uh he is he is
breaking or at least degrading the kind
of
institutional norms that successful
liberty-loving peaceful democracies need
and rely on because yes
we are a nation of laws but we are also
a nation
of of humans who have to agree jointly
we have to come to
some kind of consensus about what we're
going to do together
um and and how we're all going to act
right like that's
like the constitution is a bunch of
words
it is it has those they're important
words they matter an
awful lot but if people just all
one day decided we're not gonna we're
not gonna agree to do that anymore
then it wouldn't work anymore and so
what trump is doing
is cracking away at some of the the kind
of foundations of mutual agreement
about how we're gonna uh run our society
and in particular how we are going to
handle elections and the transfer of
presidential power
um and the the the other way of doing
that the the non-peaceful way
is through crazy conspiracies and anger
and
guns and i would much prefer i would
much prefer the peaceful way even if
it's sometimes frustrating sometimes
irritating uh speaking of frustrations
uh andrew ford
uh gets at one of mine i'll
send this as a question to nick the
biden administration
may decide to revisit net neutrality
have the last several years provided any
new evidence
to counter arguments of those in favor
of net neutrality and we'll say this uh
ajit pai
chairman of the fcc uh just announced
that he's stepping down
nick i think you're going to interview
him or we are at some point uh soon
um and uh uh just it's amazing
to see how uh we're still allowed to uh
broadcast and and do things on the
internet uh despite uh the
net neutrality going through how do you
answer this question nick
yeah i mean the way net neutrality was
implemented and discussed
uh the the removal of it uh in 2017
uh basically early 2018 it shows that it
had no good effects
uh the level of investment uh connection
speeds and the ubiquity of connections
have only increased since then and i did
actually interview
ajit pai about a week and a half ago and
in that he discussed how
compared to europe which implemented
essentially
net neutrality style rules that people
clamored for and got
uh via you know uh agency order in the
united states
they had trouble uh dealing with the
crush
of uh increases in internet traffic due
to the pandemic and whatnot
uh european regulators went to streaming
services such as uh
youtube and and netflix who uh you know
things like that
and acts asked them to throttle their
speed so that they could handle the
traffic we did not see that in the us
u.s is also doing pretty well in terms
of the rollout of 5g
and things like that so the evidence
that you don't need net neutrality
is the past several years after it was
repealed
and and that should close the case but
as the uh the writer points out
uh it is likely very likely that whoever
joe biden puts in charge of the fcc is
going to be
much more of a heavy hand of regulation
and that's problematic not just on that
but also
in a broader sense there is an attack
from both the right and the left donald
trump hates
section 230 the internet's first
amendment the 26 words that created the
internet the thing that allows
a massive user-generated content
universe he hates that donald trump
hates that
but joe biden is going to be president
for the next four years so um
there's going to be a lot of battles
over online speech it's not just the
evidence of the last couple of years
it's
the evidence of the internet up until
the obama administration
net neutrality didn't exist before then
it was um
it was in some ways a kind of a norm uh
in that
just as sort of as a default companies
uh both at the edge and the center of
the
the the network so that's sort of both
your providers like say verizon or att
and your companies like uh facebook or
netflix or sort of operate at the edge
of the internet
they all kind of worked on a on a
roughly uh net neutral
uh idea um
but net neutrality was not enshrined in
law and there and
and it what and it was it was just this
bizarre thing where people said
look without this the internet is gonna
completely melt down
and then they put it in place and
repealed it just a couple of years later
and it it never melted down it was never
a problem before
um and so net neutrality was is just
sort of like the ultimate example in
like
we're scared something might happen we
can't even really tell you what
but we're going to preemptively regulate
in a way that will
definitely prevent people from doing
good and useful things along the way
and then when it got repealed none of
the consequences came to pass
that we were warned about like the the
internet is fine you can still tweet
stuff
unfortunately and uh you know as a as pi
memory called it he said it was a
solution that won't work to a problem
that doesn't exist
that's uh one of the better little uh is
that an epigram
i never understood these words i mean uh
catherine andrew ford has a uh
second half of the question which nick
had oh my god is this the andrew ford
hour he better be ponying up some money
does libertarianism stand a chance if so
many cannot see the wisdom
of section 230 or is it all a bluff like
calls for civility and no change is
likely catherine
i um go back and forth in my
optimism about the possible success for
particularly wonky topics like this
but i will say that 2020 has given me a
little bit of hope on that front
because think about all the people who
did not know
the phrases civil asset forfeiture and
qualified immunity before this year
and now do right like if to some extent
reaching our policy goals means like
wonkifying the public or at least
wonkifying like the activist
subset of the public then like there's
some evidence that that can work
i mean the fact that people were out in
the streets
screaming the words qualified immunity
is really
heartening to me um and i think section
230 is tricky
to understand uh even people who
you know it's their day job to
understand it i think sometimes
um either through motivated reasoning or
just a misunderstanding or a different
understanding don't
get where i would like them to get but i
would strongly recommend that you
read liz nolan brown as like a section
230
explainer and guide i think um if our
traffic is any indication
lots of people are um and you know among
them
uh at least for the last little while
the guy in charge of the fcc
so um that is that all kind of adds up
to
i think you know libertarianism in
general but especially kind of the
libertarian view
but what i see as the libertarian view
of the free internet which
relies on keeping section 230 at least
the spirit of section 230
intact um it has made a lot of headway
and i i don't think that will be
entirely reversed
um even if it does take some hits under
a biden administration but again to be
clear
it's so bipartisan to want to censor the
internet and censor speech on the
internet
that you know in some ways that i guess
minimizes my concerns about the change
of
of partisan power in washington because
everybody's wrong in their own special
way but
the people who at least comprehend the
argument we're trying to put forth
um you know they're out there and and
hopefully they retain some influence
let's go to uh one more tech related
question
rather long before we get into a uh sort
of a lightning round
uh this comes from erwin rosenbaum and i
am going to throw it at
nick first for reasons that probably
will become clear
as technology and ai advance we are
becoming more and more susceptible
to external influences tristan harris
the ex-google design ethicist has been
ringing the bell loudly about how we're
being influenced by the social media
companies
who are fighting for our attention in
the new attention economy
the documentary this social dilemma
paints a frightening picture
of how these companies using knowledge
about how the brain works
obsess on and succeed at controlling our
behavior
you've all noah hirari goes further
talking about a future where ai has
fully hacked humans such that we may
willingly
relinquish our choices big choices who
to marry what to do for a living
because the machines know us better than
we know ourselves
if we accept for argument's sake that
this is where we are headed
where does libertarianism fit within
this future nicola dr nick gillespie
uh you know the first thing that we have
to do is not say if we accept this
then you know what do you do because the
whole if you accept this which is that
a bunch of engineers at google and uh
you know various online places
have figured out how the mind works and
can circumscribe all of our choices all
of our thinking all of
everything that we do how we conceive of
the world the social dilemma is a
puff piece for the people who produced
it it has no
real bearing on how people act uh what
the internet is about or anything like
that it's a throwback
to uh in the 1950s vance packard wrote a
book about the hidden persuaders about
how
psychologists and admin had finally
teamed up to completely control our
consumer choices and in a new wealthy
post-war economy
this is just that wrapped up in you know
always always in the most
cutting-edge pseudo-scientific belief
that we have figured out how to
how to to make people constrain their
choices
it goes back to people like descartes
and you know when you read the
uh the cogito you know the idea of i
think therefore i
am that's premised on the idea at the
you know at the start of the
enlightenment
that there may be an evil puppeteer who
is actually deciding everything we do
and we are just kind of puppets at the
end of a string how do we
know that what we're doing is free will
or is conscious and intentional
so you have to reject the premise of
that because if you say well ai has
perfectly figured out
you know how to control everything you
know there's no after that
um and in fact when you look at the ways
in which individuals and people and
technologies act
they are never as totalizing a force as
we
often want to believe and it's
interesting that sometimes it's the
purveyors of that technology
and sometimes it's the people who are
afraid they're being controlled
think about people in the social dilemma
are not
different than john birch society
members who were talking about you know
their precious body fluids being invaded
by fluoride and then being controlled
through the fillings in their teeth by
communist puppets like george marshall
and dwight eisenhower
what we need to be looking at is is the
world more or less responsive to human
flourishing human innovation
and individual possibilities for life
and i think
there you know not only is google
youtube
facebook twitter you know part of the
solution
but it's a demonstration project that
people around the globe
are living better lives more fully we
have a lot of threats on the horizon
but actual ai dictating how we live is
not one of them
technology has always relieved us of
choices
and what that does is it allows us to
think about different things
and in some ways make more interesting
choices
i don't really understand how
light bulbs work especially like the new
ones
that are different for some reason i've
got like actually like three or four
different types of light bulbs
surrounding me right now and i don't
feel like edison
took over the part of my brain that was
that would have been devoted to making
fire all the time
and like robbed me of of some essential
part of myself
i like the fact that i don't have to
know how light bulbs work
at all and i would actually um if you
want sort of like a really wild
extrapolation of this idea
go read e m banks's culture series which
is about a far
future in which uh super powerful ais
do control everything and there's no
resource limitations
and and you know what humans do they sit
around and create other problems for
themselves and like
find different ways to get into trouble
and to pleasure themselves and to
enjoy things and to stay interested and
to argue and like yes in fact i i
i'm gonna um leave the the pleasure
themselves like hanging out there
because there is in fact a um
this isn't a new yorker
an individual who genetically engineers
himself
in a really spectacular way i'm just
going to say and he writes a train like
that goes around a planet just
constantly it's amazing
but this is the thing is that people are
like terrified that technology is going
to take away your choice
and that you'll somehow become less than
human in fact what happens is that
technology relieves you of having to
worry about
boring day-to-day stuff like how am i
gonna light
this candle and set my house on fire
which i did once but that's another
story
or am i just gonna turn on a bunch of
lights and not worry about this and then
i can go think about other things like
how to make a great cocktail uh asks
uh and i'll set this to catherine what
do you think about the free state
project
so i as i think i've mentioned before on
this podcast
uh went to pork fest some years ago
which is their
kind of summer festival and gathering of
free staters and free state friends
and had and i was grumpy about going
because
i do not like to be outdoors i do not
really
like nature that much i've like
reconciled myself to it a little in the
pandemic
but it was like kind of inconvenient to
get there and i got there and i
thought it was so great i just really
enjoyed these weirdo libertarians living
their best weird lives
together dancing around a bonfire with
like trench coats full of drugs it was
just what you imagined and um and it
really like
it was really a beautiful demonstration
of like what might happen if you just
let
people kind of be weird in a loose
uh conglomeration together i would say
sometimes that's what working at reason
is like too
it's bonfires and trench coats full of
drugs here as well but um
but i think it's cool i think it's cool
that it's totally voluntary i think the
mechanism was cool
i have always been a little skeptical
about it coming to
full flowering and indeed it seems to be
struggling
but wish those dudes the best uh yeah
just co-sign
aggressively on all that except maybe i
like the outdoors better uh she left out
the guns
there's always oh yeah there's like it's
like drugs guns and kids
and guns and the little commerce row is
also super great people like uh
create their own stuff it's really fun i
recommend i cannot recommend highly
enough
uh people to go to pork fest regardless
of what you think
about being in the woods with a bunch of
weirdo libertarians or
uh you know the uh the the wisdom of
trying to get uh people of a certain
philosophical bent to all move to the
same state
just throw that away it's a it's a very
fun
warm uh weird great uh party uh the
other
uh event that they do annually is in the
winter
which is much tougher in new hampshire
than the summer liberty forum
and it's fantastic as well yeah very
good very good people
uh okay what is your this is
joseph hinshaw what's your favorite
twitter account you follow i'm gonna go
first so nick can't take mine
uh super 70s sports which is just this
dude
who who like posts old light beer from
miller commercials
and like pictures of billy martin
smoking in the dugout
and and god knows what else and it just
hits all of my sweet spots and
none of those have to do with politics
uh nick what's your favorite your second
favorite i'm gonna butcher her name but
i think it's marina
arral um she is a brazilian
uh artist who colorizes old photos
and has uh and a wide variety of other
things and it's
fantastic it stands in for a whole wing
of twitter
uh which just um uh
shows different things that are you know
fascinating i mean i i what i love about
twitter
i suppose is what i hate about it is
that there's always something
interesting and new in my
twitter stream but the way she humanizes
the past
by uh colorizing it in really
unpredictable and fascinating ways
cinnamon i really like eyes on cinema
and one perfect
shot one perfect shot just posts uh
great stills from movies old and
contemporary uh with credits to the
director and the cinematographer which
is important
and then eyes on cinema posts uh images
and videos
uh sort of from film history and often a
lot of behind the scenes stuff
just little clips without a huge amount
of context
they posted one the other day that was
just a whole bunch of behind the scenes
like 1980s vhs video of the special
effects and stunt work on robocop
and it was just delightful was like i
got to spend 60 seconds
watching paul verhoeven like run around
direct people on like where to put their
explosions and their broken glass and
their
smoke bombs and it's it's kind of great
it's like a
a wonderful little cinema break uh in my
feed every time it pops up
mango no i was
i was 50 50 on whether peter's one
perfect shot was going to be
cocktails or movies which is uh great
crossover
twitter cocktails are for uh i know we
don't have shots also we don't do shots
but um
the i'm actually gonna um go a little
bit in-house and recommend the
criminally
underrated twitter feed of eric bain
that dude is so good on twitter and he
gets
not enough love so if you are not
following eric who you have heard on
this here podcast in the past
who is a reason reporter of much renown
he covers trade stuff
but he is like good with the quick quip
rather than the hot take if you know
what i mean and that to me is like a
really important thing on twitter i want
quips not hot takes if at all possible
and eric
is your man quips not hot takes sounds a
little bit like a hot take
oh uh okay steven schatz
asks uh and we'll go nick first sorry
suderman who is the most libertarian
character
in tv sitcom history
can we all just say ron swanson in
unison i mean
you'd think is nick still with us yeah
i'm here
i'm here i'm trying to come up with a
non-ron swing yeah
i think we just ron yeah you know um
i'm i'm i will put it this way i think
dale gribble on king of the hill is the
purest kind of
excrements of a libertarian parody
and i love mike judge's entire fictional
cinematic universe but uh del gribble
i'm going to go with dale gribble of
king of the hill
which is one of the greatest shows on tv
or was one of the greatest shows in tv
history
i don't watch tv comedy wow
wow pretty weird uh catherine do you
have anything to add to ron swanson uh
i mean i guess i could make the case for
uh
ted danson's character in the good place
as a
uh i mean this is i guess a spoiler but
the show is over so
uh as a renegade demon
from hell who's trying to help humans be
better on their own because the powerful
forces that surround them
haven't given them enough credit for
what they can do uh
as like individuals who grow and change
so i'll i'll go with i'll go with that i
guess
i will uh you know to bring it back to
ron swanson one of
uh well
but uh one of the great things about
that is of course that he works
in the public sector i mean he's meant
to be a parody like we should all be
clear on that like well but the reason i
bring that up is because
there is this sense that if you benefit
from a system
you are not allowed to criticize it and
this is always used to kind of cudgel
people
and keep them down when they say yes but
and um
so you know that adds to the texture of
ron swanson along with
all the other stuff brian schwartz
asks why do reason and other libertarian
organization eg
the lp cato pay so little attention to
alternative voting methods
such as approval voting and ranked
choice as a means for advancing
libertarian policies brian
the assumption of your question is wrong
that's that's how i'm answering that
question
uh go just do a search on ranked choice
on our site
i've been writing about it this very uh
month um
we had actually a weird blockbuster uh
in the lead up to this election with a
scott shackford post about ranked choice
voting in maine that thing like
got ungodly traffic so in case you're
in case you feel like you're not seeing
enough volume at least maybe you can
feel confident that
people people are coming to us to find
stuff about this and they are they are
finding it and sharing it and being
happy about it
uh let's go to some uh individually
directed
questions a round i am scrolling down
and filibustering until i get to
question for kmw
uh hold on uh yes from
michael mermack catherine has stated
that
one should not vote because among other
reasons a single vote will
not make a difference in any given race
doesn't this principle
also call into question participating in
any collective activity for example
surveys
volunteering for large organizations
donating to
reason dot dot dot catherine
the difference between those activities
and voting is that those activities are
not
winner take all they're not zero sum
each dollar that you donate to reason
is a dollar that we can use productively
whereas
each vote that you vote disappears into
a great mass and you get only option a
or option b
also you will if you
dive into the kmw don't vote over you
will find me saying in many places
that my one potential narrow exception
to my don't vote rule is like listen if
you just love it
like if it feels like a great expressive
act to you
or like you just really dig the
experience
then do it but just acknowledge that
that is the spirit in which you were
doing it and i would say
a bunch of other similar group
activities
people do because it gives them joy uh
in which case they should they should go
ahead and do it
but they shouldn't be confused about the
potential impact of
of any of those activities but don't
don't you tell me what in particular
catherine yeah matt gets voting joy
which is like
okay but why question for nick from
brandon you
stated that your preferred electoral
outcome this year would be a
trump presidency with a democratic
senate because of trump's lack of a
regulatory agenda
i would argue that the reverse abiding
presidency with the republican senate is
better
considering trump's inconsistency on
regulation and lack of genuine efforts
towards actual deregulation
doesn't the stability of a president who
respects the integrity of american
political institutions
outweigh those concerns
uh yeah well you know that's the
scenario that we're going to see
and i think a lot of us and i know i was
personally i was kind of uh
energized by the electoral results
because there was a
rejection of trump uh trump as president
which i think overall is good
but there was also a rejection of kind
of the extreme forms of populism
and of kind of the democratic socialist
agenda
when you look at the ways in which the
democrats lost uh
seats in the house and did not pick up
the senate so
um you know we'll we'll see how it all
plays out
i think the biggest problem for me with
the biden win
and the situation we're going into now
is that there's every reason to believe
that the republicans and the democrats
are going to compromise
in a way that gives each of them what
they want which will mean
i think inevitably bigger government
bigger government spending
a lot of regulatory things we talked
about section 230.
earlier you have equal uh people in uh
the republican party in the democratic
party calling for the end of section 230
and of some kind of overt regulation of
speech
and uh and action on the internet so i
hope that he's right uh either way you
cut it that's what we're going to be
doing biden's early appointees already
suggest that he is
really gonna make an effort to use the
executive branch
and uh executive orders
to govern um and that is an opportunity
that is going to be afforded to him
by the expansions of executive branch
power that have happened uh
under trump obama and george w bush in
particular and so the last three
presidencies have all
just pushed executive power and
executive authority
and that's gonna mean that biden if he
can't
uh work with congress if he has uh if he
has republicans
uh in the senate um who have a majority
in the senate
which is likely but not certain given
the outcomes of the
georgia senate runoffs um i think
i think biden is really going to end up
doing a lot of governance through the
executive branch in ways that are
that are quite worrying um and that are
probably not things that trump would
have done
but that trump helped enable uh just by
basically
deciding that he was going to work
around congress
and uh and and use executive authority
question for me
from zach mayo i recall it once being
mentioned that the informal dress code
policy at reason was
dress like someone you really like is
coming into the office today to see you
and if that's true why has nothing been
done about welch's hair
uh the guy spends 20 years cosplaying as
a 1950s era pentagon suit
only to do this baffling uh zach i think
you bring up a very important
uh question i'll just say that my um
french mother-in-law
uh it was reported to me uh recently
said
he looks like he looks like someone who
has come back from vietnam and is still
working through some issues
[Laughter]
matt i i fear that you are especially
with the basement uh home office that
you're devolving into milton
from office space devolving hello
hashtag aspirational
uh yeah you know what uh there's no one
coming to my office
uh anyways uh at this point and you know
my wife likes to think that it's a uh
it's a a cry from the heart
because i'm unable otherwise to express
my pain and i think that sounds
as good as it is you are just surrounded
by french people i want to know that the
reason
the reason dress code is actually just
please
wear clothes yes um and uh especially on
which puts us as an outlier really in uh
in magazines these days i guess yeah a
question for suiterman from john losa
uh what is the most libertarian
space-centric sci-fi
tv series despite the failings of all
governments in the series i don't think
it's star wars because star wars is
always pushing a chosen one or a hero
with a destiny
to come and save everyone a metaphor for
the right government to come along and
fix things
stargate and star trek are all about
agents of the government saving the day
so i discard them as contenders what do
you think
i mean star wars is as much a movie
series as a tv series although there are
some great uh tv shows
that i would say are not super
libertarian but are surprisingly
interested in
governance um but they're not they're
not particularly libertarian
obviously the most libertarian sci-fi tv
series
is firefly um and especially if you pair
it with the movie serenity
uh which served as a kind of capper to
the uh the shortened
one season that ended up running before
this show got cancelled
the movie opens up with a little girl
in a classroom uh who is being lectured
by a teacher on
like let's call it you know an inner
ring planet that's
effectively the capital of a big empire
that spreads out in a kind of uh
space sci-fi version of the american old
west
where there's sort of outer rim planets
that are less developed and
less governed but the empire is kind of
trying to keep them
under their thumb and and bring them in
line and
it's a it is it's just this little scene
in which
the the little a little girl tells the
teacher uh like
look people basically just want to be
left alone to figure out how to live
their lives
um and to figure out what they want from
them and to not be told
and uh and the teachers just sort of
smugly respond something like we're not
trying to teach people how
what to think we're just trying to teach
them how and there's it is a
a surprisingly effective encapsulation
of the kind of arrogance of technocratic
overarching government um that's not
necessarily obviously super
authoritarian or you know it's not it's
not the kind of government that is
that you look at on the surface and
think oh my god this is big evil
government
no it's just a bunch of people who are
trying to tell other people how to live
and that's what governments even
even the governments that are better
even the governments that work that we
should
probably try and improve and that we
should support you know in certain ways
um that's what government is it's it is
a bunch of people
assuming that they know how how you
should live your life better than you
should than you do i just want to note
i've been holding out for years
for a reason group halloween costume
where we
dress as the characters in firefly even
though at this point no one would be
able to recognize us and also we're
never going to see each other again in
person
also because we have all the firefly
ship personalities
on staff what was the terrible group
costume that happened a few years ago
catherine first of all none of them are
terrible so
bite your tongue second last year we
were princess bride and it was amazing
anywho uh aaron yoshida asks a question
that i will direct
to catherine uh first oh would you
consider producing more content
like the reason roundtable podcast i'm
imagining a fifth column type
podcast where you partake of various
substances
and engage in long rants without
consideration of any schedule
bro you do not want that uh he also asks
would you consider
publishing a podcast where you read
aloud reason articles like the
intercepts spoken edition catherine
what's new on the podcast front we
would consider that we are always
looking to grow our podcast stable so
send us your suggestions
at the moment we do not plan like reason
late night
which is what it sounds like you want um
although
you know the future is um is full of
possibilities
um and we actually did at one point have
an audible edition of reason where we
had voice actors reading
uh select articles unfortunately didn't
get
quite enough uptake to be worth the
effort um
but uh you know this is we are always as
i said at the top of this podcast like
our mission our goal is to find a new
way
to get our ideas into someone's head and
hopefully
back out into the world so uh keep the
keep the suggestions coming i uh as a
co-host the fifth column we get uh um
suggestions
sporadically like hey you guys should do
a stoned fifth column and like god no
uh but uh just thinking out loud you
know
with uh nick's uh interesting like
intellectual interest and perhaps
personal interest
in exploring the vast new world
of uh of uh psilocybin and just kind of
the legalizing drugs that are happening
there
um i would love to to not necessarily
hear neck
but some staffers uh doing you know
stoned reason
would be would be pretty uh it's a
terrible idea uh
don't get me wrong that's a terrible
idea as a consumer
um uh and not as so much and a clinician
yeah i would like to hear uh smart
people be stoned just to
just to uh to confirm the idea that uh
whatever you think is really smart when
you're stoned
is just 99 of the time so when
i was making pot infused cocktails
uh for an issue of the magazine uh
at catherine's request yeah
that's my wife editorial assignment
ended up a
pot infused old-fashioned and i
i'm not gonna say it was entirely on
purpose but it wasn't exactly a mistake
didn't tell her what the secret
ingredient was
in the cocktail we were just a b testing
a no pot version and a pot version
and like an hour and a half later we
found ourselves
just like sort of came out of a trance
where we had been
monologuing critiques of
the leads in milk street which is
the uh like the sort of fancy cooking
magazine that we subscribe to
and like we just sort of realized that
like it was like 9
30 and we'd been doing that together
like at each other for like an hour so
this is
the strongest case again so if you're
asking podcast
uh for a reason on weed like it's
definitely possible that you'll get
something like that
uh i am going to read and answer a
question from james gentlemen
uh is there any hope and i'll just
listen to this slowly
is there any hope for getting some young
edgy voices
in the vein of jacob sullivan jd
tuccilli nick gillespie etc
before those guys start retiring or is
reason's trajectory towards
quote respectable journalism unquote
pretty much
set are we doomed to a future of reason
staff
being firmly entrenched in the cocktail
party
set second part of the question have you
thought about poaching writers
from aeir or the mises institute or hell
just finding some smart
twittertarians to bring on board
catherine will ultimately answer this
question
she's in charge of the decision-making
process i would just like to point out
that um it the the the correlation
between people like using the phrase
cocktail party set
in one half and mises institute
on the other is just stunning
to me like i should stop surprising me
12 years later 15 years later however
long i've been around here
um but like the imagination
uh by people who are our fans of of uh
uh the auburn alabama
people and and imagining our social
drinking here
i mean i would love to go to a cocktail
party at peter suderman's house
other than that which i haven't ever
done um uh other than that
i don't live in the beltway uh the last
time i had a cocktail party
in my front yard my 12 year old daughter
was mixing them
uh like palomas giving to my friends uh
you're i'm like a parent i don't have
cocktail parties it's just teach
them weird well think yes teach them
well exact
uh measurements peter you'll be happy to
know yeah um which they
quickly disregarded but yeah it's uh the
you know once you become a grown-ass
person
um for the most part you stop going to
cocktail you know who goes to cocktail
parties
in dc sorry to rant here um yeah really
you just like went off bro
the 26 year old like you know
khaki pants wearing interns at the
uh the ins institute for centrist uh
bipartisan studies
who are just looking for free stuff
that's the i mean it's not even cocktail
parties it's like receptions
with bad plastic glass wine and you're
like cool i don't have to pay money
for this because my rent and adams
morgan cost too much it's just a very
strange
thing but catherine do you want to
address the substance
of uh of whether we're gonna get some
more young edgy voices like uh
uh nick gillespie right like obviously i
love
me some uh jacob solemn some jd2 chili
and some nicolas b
and if i could clone them and
raise them myself uh to continue to
produce
glorious libertarian diatribes i
absolutely would
uh brian kaplan and i have this in
common and it creeps people out when he
says it too but
uh you know that's okay i stand by it um
that said i think you know
there's always a tension between uh
being kind of fun and weird and
interesting and
having people take you seriously and
listen to your suggestions and proposals
um and sometimes you gotta do both and i
think we do both right we have made
arguments over our 50 years that people
patted us on the head and said like
that's adorable but insane
uh we have made arguments that have made
people really mad i commend you to
elizabeth nolan brown's work on sex
trafficking for instance which
like you know the voting thing probably
makes people a little more bad but
the idea of um the war on sex
trafficking actually being a war
on uh consensual adults uh selling sex
is something that really really annoys
people it is i would say
edgy if i used that word which i usually
don't um
i think we do both and i think they
serve each other and um
i i wish you to believe
that uh when we ultimately
send uh jerry and nick and jacob off
in a flaming canoe to uh
to their rest uh that reason will still
be in
good totally appropriate for two
children uh let's have some molotov
cocktail parties yes
we can do them via zoom uh brian nothing
wrong with cocktail parties or
respectable journalism
but also like i actually think it's a
mistake to say that that like
nick and jd and jacob sullem are not
respectable journalists they are
well i am uh not only am i a doctor but
i'm a two-time finalist for national
magazine awards
150 years ago that really meant
something award losing journalist dr
gillespie
yes absolutely brian schnack asked a
bunch of great
short questions including one about the
baseball hall of fame that i'm not even
going to
to read or reference in any way um the
answer is
always uh you should read that question
and answer it just so people can see
what catherine looks like when you do
hmm
i can i will not answer it uh that's
great news you have a vote for the
baseball hall of fame
catherine won't vote but you can end
well
uh but you can't end well what's the
most libertarian ticket you can punch
that's just like
there's 10 votes it's a it's a nightmare
but the answer is heidi minutes as nick
points out
um but no you know what that i would say
real name
this is it is it's henry emmett manoosh
wow back in a time when germans were not
so totally i've learned to stop
questioning
nick and matt when they say absolutely
outlandish names from
like some murky time before don't you
think kurt flood
kurt flood uh yeah uh deserves speed in
the hallway
actually even as a player um he has a
pretty good case he's great uh
considering his earlier
experiments and he was a uh a hero
agency of uh of uh yeah and economic
rights
uh was his lawyer or the the principal
lawyer marv
marvin mitchelson was it marvin miller
i don't know if he was the lawyer or or
the head of the players association by
then but
uh but certainly yeah uh who's whose
memoir is
right of contract absolutely great read
uh so
go there and now you know um other
people but i'm not going to make
catherine's eyes roll out of her head uh
instead i'm going to
uh uh hit her with this schnack question
uh we love brian uh embrace your secret
statist
ban one thing without regret
explain but no need to justify katherine
oh
so many options but i mean i think i'm
just gonna go
with like discussion of baseball on the
reason podcast sorry
uh uh scooterman i would ban heartbreak
matt if i could ban one thing in this
crazy world
heartbreak now my real answer actually
is tv and airports but i
don't think that's necessarily
anti-libertarian in a correctly
structured world where airports are
privately owned thank you the end
obviously uh my answer is i would ban
government man
just like enough uh pseudomeg what would
you ban
vodka martinis
[Laughter]
he was ready but you're still
in that russia gate thing aren't you
yeah the vodka martinis
are terrible and aren't cocktails i'm
going to
uh reverse engineer the baseball
question
um so that nick and i can nod off on
this one from leonard goodnight
if the round tablers were a d and d
party
what class would you each be uh please
include and i don't think we have to
both regulars and guest stars like slade
suave enb etc
i mean obviously as artsy writer types
you're all bards
so let's rule out bard as a choice
catherine what language is this person
speaking
um first of all i love me some lenny
goodnight he's one of my faves on
twitter so hi lenny
uh and second um we can't rule out bards
because
among other things peter suterman is a
bard deep in his soul and
also plays a bard in our real dnd game
so sorry i
uh think of myself uh as my original d d
character
who was a rogue gnome i will fight you
about it if you want to talk about it we
can't we can't do everybody but like
it's it's
there's a lot of bards there's a lot of
there's a lot of human
fighters which always surprises me
because why would you be that but
actually
like maybe if you're like a libertarian
individualist who has a lot of faith in
human ingenuity you're like i'll be a
human
even in this imaginary changed though
when the game started
there were fewer i believe we had no all
human characters we had a couple of half
years that's true we had some halfsies
but
anyway that that's my answer and uh and
probably more d d than anybody
wanted um there is of course as we have
discussed a reason d d game that has
been going on for many years but its
contents are off the record oh
uh okay let's go to more uh
individualized questions
uh for catherine here from uh our good
friend juliana
j in queens um what is your favorite
robot
fictitious or real oh like that question
um so i have a a weakness although it's
i guess a guilty pleasure
for kind of original asmovian
uh robots uh i was i you know read isaac
asimov in my formative years
and um you know kind of love the
robot with the heart of gold trope um
asmov is uh was a
a real kind of centralizing technocratic
monster in many ways a product of his
uh centralizing technocratic time so
i do not uh necessarily want to move
into the worlds he built
but um you know maintain a soft spot for
for his robots um but
you know i love all robots equally
marvin the sad robot
they're all my precious children
i think i am the only uh reason staffer
who actually
lived with a robot uh my ideal friend
sarah siskind who was one of the
co-creators of mostly weekly the late
lamented web series that reason ran
with andrew heaton as well was one of
the proprietors or
operators of sophia the robot uh which
who is all over um social media but
we lived in a kind of bizarre philip k
dick version
of three's company for a while during
the pandemic because
one of the sofia robots was in our tiny
apartment that we were sharing it was
uh enough to make me really want to come
back and kill all the robots the way
that you structured your answer there
it was like we were a long way into that
sentence before it was clear that the
robot itself wasn't your girlfriend
so just uh well you know it's the robot
experience actually is what we were
going for
i will now ask a question
directed at nick from frank elect no
quiz which is the greatest name i've
ever heard even though i did also live
with heidi minutes that's why i got
pregnant
uh it says still not her real name
speaking of which
nor is aussie shrek and goss to peter
suderman uh
it says nick what that means i don't
understand
any of your cultural references has
anything significant happened after
1995.
one of us shots fired uh virtually
everything important in my life has
happened after 1995. so i
i don't know what you're talking about
is that you know uh i guess
you know matt i'll throw you in on this
too but we're like uh you know
faulkner south where the uh the past
the past isn't he you know isn't over
it's not even past uh what uh you know
we live in a world where we can freely
travel through time and space so
what's wrong with remembering the past
and kind of using it as an augmented
reality
to uh to uh to view the present not
unlike
you know the best segments in underdog
uh
brandon asks me uh and i'm just using
this part of his question to bug
catherine what is your favorite
historical baseball team
and why is it not the miracle mets
uh it's not the miracle mets uh because
uh they really sucked
that was like that was i i totally loved
them um
in fact recently i've been getting into
teams that obviously
should never have won the world series
but did because i find them to be
particularly heroic
and that actually gets to the answer of
the question the my team the anaheim
angels as they were called then won the
2002
world series with about the least amount
of star power at least the
the miracle met said tom seaver at the
top of his game the angels had like
i don't know darren erstad um and the
fact that they won
uh was uh kind of beautiful and they
played great ball the mets had a bunch
of people playing over their heads the
angels did not
but you have to love the miracle mets
also for
uh you know what they did to the
baltimore orioles who were really kind
of like the imperial
stormtroopers of of that europe
they're one world series which is uh
right and because
earl weaver is by far and away the most
overrated manager
in baseball history uh let's go to a
question for suiterman
a little bit more policy related being
the only industrialized country without
universal health care comma it puts a
greater burden on americans to justify
not accepting medicare for all or
something similar
american libertarians make convincing
arguments attributing rising health care
costs to government intervention
but often do so at the expense of
addressing those who are convinced
that single-payer works everywhere else
how would you begin
to build the argument that removing
government from health care
is a preferred and practical alternative
to medicare for all and i would just add
peter you have 30 seconds yeah so it
depends on who i'm talking to and in the
environment
right it's uh you want to you if you're
going to make this case you want to make
it to people
in a language that they understand
starting from values
that that they hold and that they share
and so a big thing that i do when i talk
to people who really think
that uh single-payer or completely
socialized systems
like the national health service exist
is i point out that those systems
have flaws and limitations and that they
often don't provide
good health to the people who are they
who they are supposed to provide
health care to and one reason is that
government systems inevitably
end up with if not explicit rationing
like you basically have in the
national healthcare system a kind of
implicit rationing
and it's because what you end up having
having are limited resources
in which government authorities decide
who gets what and when and so sometimes
that rationing as in canada
happens through lines and through
waiting and it's different depending on
your province and there's a bunch of
issues
but you have these i mean like in some
of the provinces in canada you've had
issues where
they'll decide that oh if you've got two
cataracts in your eyes we'll pay for
surgery on one of them because that's
what our budget allows
and you have to wait for months and
weeks and you know on many of these
things
and so there are just there are real
problems with socialized medicine
not just in terms of the budget and not
just in terms of the fact that it taxes
people and spends their money
but in terms of if your goal is provide
good health care
to as many humans as possible then i
think the evidence is pretty clear
that those socialized systems often fail
uh let's
we don't have a whole lot of time left
so we want to get a couple three more
maybe
uh in here um uh first one i will answer
andy newland
asks what do you all think of the tea
party 2.0
what tea party 2.0 uh he goes on do you
think attempting to infiltrate the gop
or the lp trying to be a spoiler has a
better chance of getting libertarian
policies
enacted uh andy there's this great book
called the declaration of independence
how libertarian politics can fix what's
wrong
with america written 10 years ago by
matt welch nick gillespie
um we make the argument i don't know if
it's true but but still kind of believe
it
that the future of politics uh is going
to be less about team
membership and more i mean by politics i
mean
applied policies uh fixing stuff that's
wrong
uh it's gonna be case-by-case uh
examples using
whatever tools are out there some of
them will be within government many
most will be without or on the outside
of government
um just working on ad hoc basis to do
stuff like
i don't know since we wrote the book uh
10 years ago
now we have legal marijuana in a whole
bunch of places even
legal psilocybin mushrooms in a place or
two
uh gun rights have been recognized as a
um
as an individual right which wasn't the
case you know 12
15 years ago gay marriage is legal
um a lot of things happen uh you know
the the
at least there's public opinion and a
outgoing uh president uh who also voices
this public opinion
that maybe having wars all the time is a
bad idea uh some of these
involve politics many of them do not uh
so i uh i
i'm not here to tell you like the way to
go is by working within the gop i
right now don't have a lot of faith in
the gop uh or the way to go is to join
the libertarian party maybe the way to
go is to
sit in a corner and look at baseball
statistics for a while or go to your
local city council meeting
and try to say hey look uh
stop you know over penalizing
restaurants for opening up outdoor
spaces or whatever it is
i don't think that there's one uh size
fits all
answer to that question um and i wish
everyone the best of success in all of
their experiments
and that's the memo adrian engelberth uh
writes what's a concise way this is a
really good french goodbye question
uh what's a concise way to define
libertarianism
uh and it goes on to add how do you
approach pollution in a libertarian
mindset
if you apply do no harm pollution is
something regulations should be in place
to stop
this then drives government growth which
seemingly is a bad libertarian thing to
support catherine
there's a bunch of different elevator
pitches for libertarianism that i like
uh
i have long been grooving on the idea
that
libertarianism seeks to maximize choice
and the free movement of people and
goods across
borders or maybe if you want to get
fancy the free movement of people
goods and ideas across borders
that to me really captures a lot of the
spirit of what libertarianism
can and should be up to right now um so
i i recommend that one to you as your
elevator pitch free minds
and free markets and that's a good one
too well done next what's your
what's your latest uh version of
libertarianism
3.0 pitch uh you know i think it's uh
individualism as the starting point of a
system of interacting with people that's
free fun
and fair i believe i think we do need to
re-up
uh kind of how we talk about
libertarianism and one of the ways i've
been thinking about it more and more is
as a system that really talks about
autonomy and empathy
um because you know we uh you
you do unto others as you would have
them do unto you
uh and i would like to go to the policy
question about pollution
uh air pollution uh water pollution
other forms of pollution are mostly
commons problems and uh got 20 years ago
or more
lynn scarlett who had a long time uh
figure in the free market
environmentalism movement put forth a
kind of vision of how do you deal with
something like air pollution which is
dicey
and you come up with ways to kind of
identify what the costs are
and then tax the appropriate people to
help remediate the issues with that and
to minimize things
it doesn't have to lead to bigger and
bigger government
that's a policy choice if you're going
to dictate particular technologies
or prohibit certain types of behavior
but there are ways around that and i
would um
you know looking back it's in the mid
late 90s
lin's cover story about a new
environmental vision is is really worth
looking at and in many ways it's been
implemented uh just
you know and it helps reduce the amount
of uh pollution
and speed up the rate of innovation so
that we're doing more stuff
with less things in general prices and
property rights
even if they are somewhat synthetic in
nature are always preferable
to heavy-handed technocratic regulatory
alternatives
uh let's go to two final questions
here um
[Music]
turd and a punchbowl question
potentially mike smith what is one major
topic
issue or policy that you strongly
disagree with relative to your other
co-hosts catherine wow you're just going
to
throw that one in my lap huh thanks um
yeah i think i mean the the
at base will we'll go back to the very
beginning of this podcast which is the
the anarchy question i know that lots of
libertarians would rather not be
associated with
anarchism and i don't blame them a lot
of anarchists are kind of terrible
maybe even including me but i think that
uh
you know it really there is many people
were attracted to reason or are
attracted to libertarianism generally
because it's at least trying to
answer all of the questions that you
might have
about politics political economy and
associated issues
with a coherent system and
you know to me when you really start to
ask the question
well how do you justify
any government how do you justify taking
people's money from them and doing
something they didn't want done with it
how do you justify restricting people's
movement and speech
which is what government ultimately does
if it exists at all and i think the
answer is you can't
um and that you shouldn't you shouldn't
be in that business it's the wrong
business to be in so
you know i'm as i say i am always happy
to
not have that fight i don't think having
that fight is super useful
but i think ali all are
you know ultimately wrong not to go
there with me uh status
man uh what is your uh what do you
that's not going to kill that's not
going to catch
uh what's your uh area figuring out
disagreement
status um i don't know i mean
you know one thing i would sort of say
is that when we disagree on this podcast
it sometimes might sound to
casual viewers like we really are
strongly disagreeing but in fact
you know we've all worked together for
uh more than a decade now
and we actually agree on a huge amount
even if
sometimes this what this podcast ends up
doing is focusing on the places where we
do disagree and on some of these
relatively nuanced disagreements in part
because that's what's interesting to
talk about and interesting to sort of
hash out
um so i actually find myself just wildly
more in agreement
overall with my podcast uh co-hosts and
colleagues here
than i do and it's it's relatively small
areas where we where we disagree i would
say probably the
the the most common or sort of most
frequently surfaced disagreement is
is between me and nick just over kind of
how to think about
uh donald trump as president and whether
that is
um whether it's sort of a joke whether
it's kind of entertaining or whether
it's
uh kind of apocalyptic for
for uh for for a good democratic
um you know uh free society um
and i will admit i go back and forth and
i think in some ways it's all of those
things and i think
nick probably has uh a different idea
about how to think about trump and
and what he represents than i do um at
the same time i will also say that
nick has taught me a lot and i i
frequently um
i try to actually incorporate his ideas
and i find them useful and it's good for
me
i think to sort of hash out some of
those disagreements um i feel like i'm
i'm better at thinking about those
questions and about thinking about
them holistically and thinking around
them and sort of how to
how to apply them in my work and in sort
of just my thinking about
american politics because because of
nick and because of the
of the smart and thorough ways in which
he sometimes disagrees with me yeah
thank you very much peter that's very uh
humbling
and i appreciate it because i've also
learned a lot from you
particularly in the the weekly podcast
discussions
i would say you know just very quickly
touching on the issue of trump
i you know and i think this is kind of
part of the root of the disagreement i
see trump more as an effect
than as a cause and of course there's
always a feedback loop
and trump is a particularly unique
historical character but i think
the forces that produced him continue
we'll continue i mean we
he doesn't exist anymore effectively
he's gone and he won't be spoken of much
after january 20th i'm fairly confident
of that
but the forces that's already got a pack
he's getting ready for 2024
you'll trust me uh this one or we'll
we'll see we can we'll check back on
that but
um you know the loss of trust and
confidence in institutions public
private third sector
um are what produced them and those
forces have not abated at
all what i would say matt is that i
think the biggest area of disagreement
on a specifically specific policy
question in 2020
for me has been the lockdown i think the
lockdowns were ill-conceived
um as a as a policy response to the
pandemic
um and they are you know uh
unprecedented
and and certainly in in recent or in in
historical memory we just haven't had
this type of
experience uh and i think it was a dumb
way to respond to the pandemic
and then on top of it we see every day
we see that it is poorly implemented and
you know just i'm living in california
for a few months
and when you see mayor after mayor
governor
after governor here demanding that
people shelter in place and then go out
to restaurants or contradict their own
rules that they're pushing on other
people
you see how this is a combustible mix
and i think i
am more uh bothered by that or or
um you know i i don't want to give any
quarter to
the way that the locked ends were
conceived or um or
implemented and i think that's a point
of uh friction
i'm not sure there's a huge disagreement
between the room and all that i would
add uh my
um uh it's it hasn't come up
on the podcast at all i don't think and
i've certainly i don't think i've
written about it at all
but my most um uh anti-libertarian
thought one of many is that
intellectually i have a hard time
uh not supporting an increase
in payroll taxes after the threshold
removing the
the the limit uh whatever it is now of
the cap after 135 or 150
000 um if the argument about social
security is that it we can't
um pay for it as we go in addition to
taxation being theft
um but is that you know it's actually
unsound
you de-unsound it by lifting that cap
um so that's i i struggle with that
myself
i'm not inviting my co-host to yell at
me right now but
you asked the question of how we might
disagree um i'm gonna
you can make that argument but one thing
you have to reckon with is
just that every time that gets put into
political discussion
people want to take the pot of money
that you raise by lifting the cap
and they want to spend it on like 15
different things
not just social security so what ends up
happening is
is it's like oh i i got a freelance
check for
whatever amount this month and i'm going
to go out
to a bar tonight and then also i'm going
to go and buy it right and you're just
going to and like you spend it
six times and and it ends up being even
if like
i mean you can make the argument yes we
should fund social security
according to its actual obligations
using the tax that pays for social
security
but that sounds like a good one where it
ends lock box
um let's go to our final question and
thank you all for submitting them and
sorry to not get through all of them um
but that
such is the nature of the beast um this
comes from kevin
this is a a chance to to dream a little
bit
which i think we all need especially but
not only the four of us
and those of us whose names aren't
mentioned but who help
bring this to you every week uh who uh
we thank very much
um namelessly uh kevin asks uh when we
finally get to the end
of covid what is the big thing you plan
on doing you haven't been able to really
do
during covid catherine have people come
to my house and eat dinner with me
i really like to have people come to my
house and eat dinner and it's not
a thing that i've been able to do and
i'm looking forward to doing it
like just you know picking up the kids
from school
and being like you want to come over for
pizza like i'm not talking about fancy
georgetown dinner parties i'm talking
about seeing people
in your house and hanging out um you
know
we talked last week or we talked on
monday um my
what my what was i consuming
recommendation was about the importance
of
kind of dinners and community meetings
and meetings and homes for
um the jewish community in williamsburg
that was depicted in the show unorthodox
but
you know i was also obviously just
subtweeting myself like i want to have
people come into my house
and eat the hollow bread with me uh nick
what is a a big
thing the first big thing you plan on
doing that you haven't been able to do
you know i like uh live events including
i'll throw in movie theaters go to movie
theaters and that
that cause i i you know spoiler alert
i've i've had gatherings i've been to
gatherings and things like that
um although it's it is awful you know um
but it's
you know for me uh the simple pleasures
of going to a movie theater
going to live events sporting events
things like that at this point i'll even
say funerals
uh you know that's most looking forward
to going to a funeral
with lots of people uh suderman
i mean cocktail bars and movie theaters
are were a big part of my life and i
haven't been to one
um in months but i will also say uh i
have a bar
here behind me right you can see it well
that's not a green screen it was
completed at the end of 2019
and i was uh i was able to have people
over
just a few times before the world shut
down and i have not been able to serve
people a drink
at the bar in my house in my backyard
yes i've had a few people in small
groups over
um but i've not been able to serve
people a drink at my house and i i
really miss being able to do that it's
fun it's a it's a
it's fun to make the drinks it's fun to
prepare them it's fun to think about
them but it's also really fun to have
people over and to make something
wonderful for them
and that's not something that i've been
able to do and i really miss it
uh and i would uh say that it would be
accompanying my family to go visit
uh the french side of our family
um not only is it uh just critical for
kids to see their grandparents and
extended family
uh in their case it's also uh important
for uh
linguistic reasons um for my wife's
morale
and also for mine i love and turns out
kind of need
to get physically out of my country and
culture
on a pretty regular basis or else i
start
becoming the jack nicholson character in
the shining um
so uh yeah looking forward to to uh to
to beating the cabin fever
uh breaking out and uh being surrounded
by a language that i can't possibly
comprehend and uh daydreaming about the
1969 baltimore orioles
and uh can i also throw in
just to kind of be a little more on
theme here
one of the very last things that we did
in the before times uh was have
a happy hour here at the reason office
that was about the glories of global
trade it was in fact
uh sponsored in part by scott ewin who
asked our first question
and it was super fun and we had
french cheese and illegal soybeans and
uh some nice little talks about trade
and a bunch of booze
and uh i very much
look forward to having people come back
in the recent office to like
have a little panel and talk about stuff
and then have a good time together
that's one of the reasons that we have
this office here in dc
and that we um we try to regularly throw
parties
here is because it's good to
hear from our readers and hear from
people who are our fans and people who
just heard about the event and want to
come and meet us like that's
that's good for us hopefully it's fun
for y'all um so we promise to let you
know
listeners and viewers uh when the office
is reopened and we can
have you over again for a drink yeah i
miss the in-person
reason community experience a lot
uh amen um thus uh wraps up our
reason community experience a little bit
more remotely
more zoomly um and this special edition
of the uh reason roundtable podcast
thank you for listening and watching
i can't imagine uh what it's like on
your eyes um
and uh thank you for donating you donate
by the way by going to reason.com
donate that right catherine something
like that yeah uh yeah and and as you do
and there's lots of different levels of
giving and it's fun whatever
um but please include feedback and it
doesn't have to be
all about bad haircuts
but no stuff you like stuff you don't
like um things you'd like to see in the
podcast some of the questions that we
didn't raise here
were really good suggestions for the
podcast and thank you for them uh or
like other podcasty type of things that
we could do
um we uh respond and uh and
think about them and take them to heart
uh this is a wonderful
time of the year to kind of um
think about and put our fingers in um
the relationship that we have
with the reason audience which literally
makes this possible it's not just like
oh this makes it all possible
but like it actually makes it all
possible um uh you know um
the this is coming out on thursday i'll
have my
uh first webathon post but sort of talks
about
the way that um uh having a broad
donor base of people uh allows us to
have a little continuity where you have
the last 20 editors
or last 20 years worth of editing of
reason is
no 20 editors that's for the new
republic we we've only had a few um but
anyways
it allows us to have continuity uh and
to maintain those relationships over
time
um with the with uh with all y'all so
thank you for that
uh catherine do you want to say any last
words just
thank you so much for your supportive
reason and for listening all the way to
the end of this godforsaken thing
and uh for listening all the way to the
end so many weeks as we can tell that
you all do
um and we'll be back on monday bye
bye everyone thank you for great
questions